You'd like to get married but you have no idea how it goes.
The allele ceremony,
1 time your 2 families are installed,
1 room for men and 1 room for women.
And the Imam has arrived The ceremony begins with the
Imam asking for your consent to you,
the bride-to-be He will also ask your legal guardian if he agrees to
give your hand to your future husband Then the Imam asks if your future
husband has planned 1 dowry 1 time you said yes,
the Imam would make 1 traditional marriage oath This will usually be
based on specific prayers and passages of the Qur'an.
,
you can sign your religious marriage certificate.
It is optional.
You can sign it in front of your 2 witnesses or in front of rosavic.
You are married now.
Place to the party,
the ceremony of the dates of the milk,
the exchange of the wedding rings and the walima,
the meal.
Let me know if you are interested in the halal ceremony,
but this time at the mosque.